do you have an evening routine yeah
sometimes not all the time hey guys just
got home from a hectic day in the
hospital but this week I'd love to share
with you my evening or night routine
whatever it is you want to call it
everything I do from the moment that I
get home all the way to the moment at
which I go to bed I'd love to rest but I
can't just yet because it's gym time cuz
it's gym time you're gonna hear a lot of
people talk about how it's not smarts
exercise at night because it messes with
your sleep it ruins the amount of REM
sleep you get and I don't think that's
true for everybody I hear a lot of
patients that do exercise at night it
actually helps them fall asleep faster
and get better quality sleep try it try
working out in the morning try working
out at night and see what works for you
just got back from the gym the first
thing I like to do right after the gym
is to get my dinner ready why after the
gym
it creates an insulin spike within your
body which drives the nutrients into
your muscles that are now nutrient
depleted I have my veggies I have some
carbs you want to eat at least 2 to 3
hours before going to sleep because if
you eat immediately before going to
sleep your body starts creating a lot of
gastric acid within your stomach and
that gastric acid end up spilling right
back out into your esophagus when you
lay down in bed do you eat before going
to sleep yes a lot yes and I know I
shouldn't good pretty much yes within an
hour probably I must say I had cheated
some Chinese food before sleeping at
night doctor would probably say give me
an hour to digest the food plan and
sleep
excuse me water is really important for
you here not only have you been sweating
during all that work you've put into the
gym but also water speeds up your
metabolism most people don't know that
but countless studies have proven that
when you're well hydrated your
metabolism works that much better one of
the last things I do before I go to
sleep for my evening routine is take my
little husky out for a walk right Roxy
Roxy's obviously got to get her evening
walk in she's got to use the bathroom
whoa dodging branches I don't like doing
work at night I'd much rather wake up in
the morning earlier than go to sleep at
night later plus at night I get all
these distractions people texting me I'm
looking at social media but in the
morning all of that is quiet no one is
on social media no-one's messaging her
at 5:00 a.m. and trust me there is
something I don't mind taking out the
time to do and that's planning my
following day
it certainly eases my anxiety to put all
the things out on paper that I have to
accomplish the next day allows me to
stay on track allows me to stay focused
and most importantly takes away that
burden of having to go to sleep worrying
that you need to wake up and remember
certain facts just put it down on paper
and forget about it it really does allow
you to stay on track the following day
and be better suited to execute the same
nighttime routine and when you do that
your brain stays in a pattern and
remember your brain loves patterns a lot
of the top CEOs talk about something
called decision fatigue what is decision
fatigue like getting tired on purpose I
have not heard of that term what's that
decision fatigue is when your mind gets
so tired of having to decide between
option a and option B that it ultimately
just makes any decision without fully
thinking out the process
at night you want to have only dim
lighting around and the reason for that
is when you have bright lights or you
have white lights blue lights it really
does affect your melatonin which hurts
how fast you're able to fall asleep and
really the quality of your sleep
altogether
also don't do the planning process in
bed the only things you should be doing
in bed is sleeping or having sex
you smell coffee sex I don't know baby I
never looked do you brush your teeth at
night my boss just floss yes
every day every night sure yeah three
times a day for sure I do I brushed my
teeth I brushed my teeth like two to
three times a day yes my mom's a dentist
absolutely twice a day we're all
brushing our teeth at night I hope from
cardiovascular protection keeping your
heart healthy decreases and gingivitis
cavities all these problems that you do
not want just brush your teeth twice a
day for at least two minutes that's the
official recommendation time to floss
yes play with this little white string
and guide it across your teeth and clean
your gums yes it prevents tooth decay
yes it prevents gum disease but also it
prevents inflammation in your entire
body we've shown that those who have
heart attacks generally have poor dental
health as well so take care of your
teeth floss often and floss daily it's
really crucial to your health do you
floss definitely are you lying
totally no that's my one downfall of
being a dentists child you know your mom
might see this yeah she'll be
disappointed do you floss yes are you
are you lying no no no I blot but you're
lying I'm not lying
are you lying I'm lying a little bit do
you vote no okay he's honest next we're
gonna be talking about how I maintain my
body's largest organ Oh skin a lot of
people have very complicated skin
regimens where they're putting on one
lotion after another with a toner this
that in a specific order it's really too
much I like to keep things simple as I
do in every other aspect of my life I'd
like to use a really good quality face
wash with some exfoliant in it rub it on
my face take some of the dry skin off
and then I like to follow it up with
some moisturizer because your skin does
get dry especially at night when we have
the air conditioners the heaters running
I will dedicate a video to just take
care of your skin in the near future be
on the lookout my nights finally coming
to a conclusion I planned the rest of my
day tomorrow I got all my
out of the way now it's time for me to
just unwind catch up on my latest
Netflix shows today I'm gonna give El
Chapo a chance I've heard some great
things about the show from buddies of
mine in this video I'm not gonna cover
sleep because I think sleep is such an
important topic that it deserves its own
video I know some of you have parts of
your nighttime routine that are totally
unique I'd love to hear about them leave
it down below in the comments I'll
respond I'll chime in with some medical
advice you haven't yet definitely hit
subscribe and most importantly have a
great night after dinner is generally
the time I take to sit down and answer
all of your comments in social media you
guys put a lot of effort into writing
your questions and comments on my social
media so I want to take an equal amount
of effort to respond instead of just
giving you a like or a thanks reply it's
incredibly important that you switch all
of your devices to night shift mode it's
a specific mode that allows those
devices to decrease the amount of blue
light that they expose you to studies
have shown that the more blue light or
short wavelength light that you're
exposed to the worse your quality of
sleep is because you're getting less REM
sleep and also the harder it is for you
to fall asleep so switch all your
devices to night shift mode and save
yourself that headache do you have an
evening routine ah kind of yeah do I
have to tell you what it is
it's your I usually take a shower and I
wash my face off
when you say wash your face off that
sounds dangerous what do you mean do you
have an evening routine before you go to
sleep and if so what do you do
I eat smoke okay and maybe how do you
reduce anxiety before going to sleep I
cycle for like 50 miles you will really
reduce your anxiety doing that of that
you can be sure